[Music]
on this saturday night
pandemic records across canada the even
more desperate demand for the vaccine
people who are actually giving the shots
on the front line should also be calling
the shots
the challenges of getting the shot to
the most vulnerable
the growing kovid 19 crisis in the first
nations community
what's the federal plan plus basic
income for the disadvantaged i wasn't
making enough money to live
the push to keep temporary benefits
after the pandemic
and the canadian couple's custody battle
we're doing this
because we love them why a court in peru
won't let them see their grandchildren
[Music]
global national with robin gill
[Music]
good evening and thank you for joining
us it was another record-breaking day in
canada's
biggest coven 19 hot spots with new
daily highs of kova 19 cases
alberta is reporting 1879 new cases in
the last
24 hours the most recorded in that
province in a single day
ontario recorded 1859 cases
and quebec has become the first province
to record over
2 000 new cases
nowhere is the situation more dire than
in canada's long-term care homes
when the vaccine finally rolls out there
are calls for the first doses
to protect the most vulnerable abigail
beeman has our top story tonight
barbara baggs died in an ontario
long-term care home in october
her daughter joanne not allowed to see
her during the first wave of the
pandemic
her being isolated me not being allowed
in i would have been
all over that so much earlier you know
maybe she could have kept the use of her
hands
maybe she didn't have to suffer like
that so long
beggs now worries about her father in
long-term care she wants to make sure
essential family visitors like her have
access to the vaccine in the first round
our loved ones cannot afford
being barred from us once again the
thing we've not heard yet
in the news that we are waiting for is
clear
clear messaging around the
prioritization of our long-term care
seniors our residents
our staff and our essential visitors
provinces are responsible for decisions
like that but a military planning
directive obtained by global news
shows track 1 vaccines those first 6
million doses
will be handled by a federally
coordinated strategy
because provinces don't have the
infrastructure nor experience
and the federal vaccine advisory
committee recommends
long-term care residents and staff be
vaccinated first
we hear information about when this
vaccine is going to be ready to be
basically put into people's arms and yet
we still don't have the
list of priority people who are going to
get it or how they're going to get it
those are actually the types of issues
that we are actively discussing with our
counterparts in the provinces and
territories
it's a complex process especially for
the pfizer vaccine expected to be
approved first
it needs to be stored in ultra-cold
freezers and not
move too much so i think the quick
question now is
what models are ideal for
vaccinating people that might not be
mobile
we're going to need to start having
these conversations with thousands of
substituted decision makers so you can't
just you know
be told within a day that the vaccine is
coming the this sector needs to be
involved
and right now they're kept in the dark
people who are actually giving the shots
on the front line should also be calling
the shots
palliative care physician dr amit arya
specializes in long-term care
he says those in the sector need a seat
at the table in the planning
i think it would reassure people to have
a clear plan in place to know these are
the benchmarks this is the plan
with an understanding that's some
flexibility the ontario government tells
global news it will have more to say on
all pieces of its vaccine rollout plan
soon
abigail beeman global news ottawa
ottawa will send canadian forces rangers
to assist with the copen 19 response in
a remote indigenous community
in manitoba the military confirms six
rangers will head to the shematawa
first nation once on the ground they
will help distribute
vital support including food firewood
and care packages
it's a flying community located 745
kilometers from winnipeg
and it's home to about 1300 people as of
today there are 144 confirmed cases of
coven 19.
the test positivity rate in the
community is 68 percent
it's just over 13 percent for the entire
province
there are daily flights carrying
patients to winnipeg and a local
gymnasium has been converted into a
self-isolation facility
for people who have tested positive an
infectious disease expert
specializing in indigenous health tells
global news
capacity needs to be built up in remote
first nations communities
and that they must be a priority when a
covet 19 vaccine is ruled out
we're doing what we can for canadians
that are not indigenous
these communities are are in trouble we
know that once it gets in there
it can go widespread and already we see
that there's
higher uh percentages of first nations
people
in the hospital in manitoba higher
percentages of icu
admissions and death in manitoba
indigenous people make up 30 percent of
all current coven 19 hospitalizations
and 42 percent of all icu
patients at least 47 indigenous people
have died from kova 19 in the province
including a boy under the age of 10.
a manitoba church has lost a legal fight
to hold drive-in services
the springs church in winnipeg has been
fined 32
thousand dollars by holding services in
its parking lot
that's a violation of public health
orders the pastors took the province to
court arguing it's no different from
sitting in a drive-through lineup
or waiting at a red light but the judge
sided with the manitoba government which
insists
online church services at home protect
lives a popular canadian singer is out
of a job
for taking part in an anti-mask rally
mark donnelly performed today at a
protest against covet 19 restrictions
he's best known for singing the canadian
anthem at vancouver connects games
but the team fired him last night saying
donnelly does not represent the team
and that everyone should follow
provincial health orders
in the u.s coven 19 has surpassed heart
disease as the leading cause of death in
america
more than 11 000 people lost their lives
in just seven days
and as jennifer johnson explains health
experts warn it could get worse
if new measures are not brought in
for the first time the u.s centers for
disease control and prevention
is recommending universal mask wearing
at all times outside your home
doctors say the pandemic has entered a
new phase of high-level transmission
more deaths than in the entire vietnam
war just in the past two months
and the next two months are likely to be
as bad or likely worse
starting next week the food and drug
administration will begin issuing
emergency use authorizations to vaccine
makers
hoping within days health care workers
and those in long-term care facilities
will start to get immunized
getting the nursing home residents
vaccinated in december
when they make up such a significant
point of hospitalizations
we'll start to see that impact you know
in late
late january once approved the federal
government will ship vaccine doses to
each state
hospitals and pharmacies will then
administer them the big chain say
they are ready this is a process that is
not new for us
we have serviced long-term care
facilities for many years
now the strain is taking its toll on
health care workers with over 100 000
americans hospitalized with the virus
it is difficult nurses are the
last person that they will see in their
last breath
many governors are ordering new lockdown
measures some are furious people are
still going to large gatherings
like this secret young republicans gala
in new jersey
attended by a florida congressman that
is representative matt putz
sorry matt gates i hope you're watching
matt you are not welcome in new jersey
leaders are frustrated too many
americans are still not taking this
pandemic seriously
as families continue to bury loved ones
this oklahoma man lost four of his
siblings
i'll see him again
you gotta believe that larry anashat
also tested positive for covet 19 in
october
but he was one of the lucky ones in his
family to survive
jennifer johnson global news washington
russia has started rolling out its
homegrown coronavirus vaccine
the shots are being offered to people
from high-risk groups including medical
workers and teachers
but it's only been given to people
between 18 and 60 years old who don't
suffer from chronic illnesses
in august russia gave the two-shot
sputnik v
regulatory approval despite tests only
being done on 76 people
the vaccine has not finished the
advanced studies needed to ensure its
effectiveness
and safety this coming week britain will
start its first round of coven 19
vaccinations
it's a major logistical and life-saving
initiative
the united kingdom granted emergency
approval to the pfizer vaccine on
wednesday
the vaccines are made in belgium and the
first batches have arrived in the uk
via the euro tunnel here's our europe
bureau chief crystal gomansing
on what happens now i just wanted you to
confirm that you have consented to this
vaccine practices and procedures are
being rehearsed as the nation
gears up nervous excited that there's
something out there that can protect us
as well as our patients
the uk government has a targeted attack
plan with a focus on those
most at risk of dying from covet 19.
because the pfizer biontech vaccine has
very specific
temperature storage requirements
inoculations will initially take place
in hospitals
involving older individuals and medical
staff
military personnel have also been called
in to assist
in the rollout especially when it gets
to the community stage
the minister in charge of vaccine
deployment tweeted from a planning
session
friday writing the excellent
coordination in place
across the system will be crucial i'm
healthy
i want to rely on my own immune system
so i would not get the vaccine the world
has stopped since a year
so we all want to get out and be safe
even those who say they'll take the
vaccine
have questions about its safety it was
tested in clinical trials involving more
than 42 thousand people
half were given the vaccine the worst
side effects were said to be headaches
and fatigue the public can be
absolutely confident that every rigorous
check has been done
to reach the judgment that we reached
that the benefits
far outweigh any risk that message has
been shared
repeatedly since the vaccine was granted
emergency use
by the uk's regulator and it will
continue to be shared with every person
who rolls up their sleeve
for the shots starting next week crystal
gamansen global news
london tonight there are calls to make
the canadian emergency response benefit
or serb
permanent in 2017 ontario implemented a
pilot project to look into the idea of
basic
income essentially people were given a
set amount of money to cover housing and
food
but that program was cancelled tonight
michael couture takes a closer look at
bringing it back
nationally three years ago
jesse gollum never had time to do
something like this
she was stuck working four dead end jobs
for up to 80 hours a week
i didn't really feel like human when i
was doing those jobs because like
you make money so that you can live and
i was
but i wasn't making enough money to live
in 2017 golem was part of the ontario
government's pilot project to provide
a basic income to 4 000 low-income
earners
just a few months later the newly
elected progressive conservative
government
scrapped the project claiming it was a
failure
golem channeled her anger into action
creating a portrait series called
humans of basic income there's roland
you said he struggled with addiction
and homelessness but basic income
helped him get out of poverty and then
he went to school
and got into a trade and then the
pandemic hit exposing societal cracks
especially for racialized and
disadvantaged communities
the canada emergency response benefit
became a lifeline to millions of
canadians
and now there's a push to continue it i
do think that basic income and policies
associated with it have the potential to
improve health outcomes but also reduce
health care utilization like a stay in a
hospital or a visit to an emergency
department
ontario's project wasn't the first in
1974 the small town of dauphin manitoba
became the test case for something
dubbed mincom
researchers wanted to see if people
stopped working after you gave them
a basic income but that didn't happen
according to evelyn farger who studied
the program decades later
her study found the vast majority of
those employed stayed employed
so the people who left school at age 16
certainly got a job at the time
they were working in the short run but
over over the longer run they would have
had far fewer opportunities and they
would have been able to offer their own
children fewer opportunities as well
detractors say it's too expensive and we
can't afford it
in july the parliamentary budget officer
was asked to look at the cost of a
post-pandemic
guaranteed income program and it's
estimated to cost anywhere
between 47 and a half and 98 billion
dollars
there is cross-partisan support for some
kind of livable
income program but it's not the
government's top priority yet
i think if there's any country that can
do this like we have a chance to
not only build a better world and lead
an economic revolution we have a chance
to lead something on a world
stage mike licouter global news ottawa
for an in-depth look at universal basic
income be sure to tune in to the new
reality tonight with donna friesen
coming up is there a behind the scenes
negotiation to free the two michaels
it's been two years since canadians
michael spavar and michael kovrick were
detained in china
their arbitrary detention followed the
arrest of huawei cfo
mong wang zhou in vancouver on a u.s
extradition warrant
there are reports the american justice
department is in talks with china to
secure her release
so could that potential deal secure the
release of the two canadian men
let's bring in mercedes stevenson
mercedes
robin right now that answer remains
unknown
on friday prime minister justin trudeau
wouldn't comment on the alleged deal
between china and the united states
on the west block deputy prime minister
christia freeland will be joining us
with her take
she is hesitant as you can imagine to
comment on the case
because of sensitivities around the two
detained canadians
but here is some of what she had to say
about her personal views on china
one thing which is personal to me
mercedes when it comes to china
and that is you know when i was foreign
minister i worked hard
on the cases of michael kovrick and
michael spavor
i got to know the families of these
brave canadians
and it is totally unacceptable to me
that they are not here in canada
canada's priority is always going to be
to get these brave canadians home i'll
talk to freeland about whether she has
any reassurances from the incoming biden
administration
that the release of these two canadian
citizens will be a priority
freeland says it's important to work
with the biden administration
but at the moment it is still president
donald trump
who is in charge that given the trudeau
government has a very good relationship
she says
with president-elect joe biden they know
as
as do uh american political leaders
across political lines know that this is
a priority for canada we've had great
support
in the house in the senate uh for canada
for michael kovrig and michael spavor
we've had some bipartisan votes and
support there
and that's important and robin as you
said next week marks
the two year anniversary of michael
spavor and michael kovrig
being held in china it's clear that
whatever happens in the hmong wong joe
case
there will be an impact on their
detainment and we will certainly be
watching that story closely
over here on the west block robin all
right thanks for that mercedes
still ahead a bc family's final push to
get custody of their grandchildren
in peru
thousands gathered outside the indian
consulate in toronto to show support for
farmers in india
similar demonstrations were held in
other parts of canada
farmers have been protesting india's new
laws which deregulate the price of crops
a bc couple is making one last legal
push to see their two grandchildren
next week their lawyer will appear
before peru's superior court to ask for
custody of the ten
and seven-year-olds or at the very least
visitation rights
the children's father is a fugitive
charged with killing their mother
and the children are living with their
paternal grandmother as romina daya
reports the family says this latest
court
fight is their last hope
one last fight to see their
grandchildren
the decision now in the hands of the
superior
court in lima peru this being our
our final shot i really really wish
that this group of judges does a serious
job
in looking after the welfare of these
children look at it objectively
al and kathy cassatkin say they've been
banned
from visiting their grandkids 10 and 7
who are currently living with their
paternal grandmother we're doing this
because we love them
and that their mother loved them more
than life
kim died for her children she died
because she stayed there for her
children
lima november 26 2016.
it is the last time kimberly cassatkin
is seen alive her partner christopher
franz
vitake has been charged with femicide
the killing of a woman under peruvian
law kassakian's body
has never been found but chilling
surveillance video from the couple's
building
reveals franz moving a heavy bag he can
barely lift
according to court evidence kassakin's
body is suspected to be inside
franz denies it claiming it's camping
gear
franz is now a fugitive a criminal trial
impossible until he's found
17 trips to peru the cassattons
have spent their retirement savings
fighting for justice
they wanted to be in lima for this final
custody battle
but then kovitt hit you know my heart
doesn't give up
but you you it's like banging your head
into a brick wall
the custody case set for december 9th
the cassations
hoping they're at least granted
visitation
if they don't win that's it i'm
exhausted
from it we've had so many trips and so
many frustrations
it's time to just say we did what we can
and i accept that it's
i've given up i feel bad about it but at
the same time i'm
this can't go on romina daya global news
time to shine up next the cover girl
changing the world
and she's just 15.
britain's royal air force captured these
rare images of what's believed to be the
world's
largest iceberg it measures around 4 200
square kilometers
that's more than six times the size of
toronto the iceberg is drifting towards
the british overseas territory
of south georgia a teenager from
colorado has been named time magazine's
first ever kid of the year gatanjali rao
is a scientist and inventor and she's
only 15. and in her short career she has
created apps to tackle
contaminated drinking water cyber
bullying and the opiate crisis
rao beat over 5 000 nominees for the
title
i don't think i can say there was like
an aha moment where i was like this is
what i want to do
it was rather just like this continuous
like learning and loving more about stem
and science and technology
i cannot see a world filled with
kindness without science and technology
being involved
i've been wanting to change the world
and hopefully i'm i am changing the
world
the teen says she wants to prove you
don't have to be an older white man to
be a celebrated scientist
times says the new title will be a
barometer for the rising leaders of
america's youngest generation
and that is global national for this
saturday i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is the vancouver
skyline thank you for watching
good night
you